>>> THIS MORNING, NEW CNN
REPORTING ON WHAT FOX BOSS
LACHLAN MURDOCH IS SAYING
PRIVATELY ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.
CNN'S SENIOR MEDIA REPORTER
OLIVER DARCY BROKE THIS STORY.
OLIVER, WHAT IS HE SAYING
PRIVATELY?
>> YEAH, IN PRIVATE, YOU KNOW,
YOU WOULDN'T EXPECT LACHLAN
MURDOCH, THE CEO OF FOX, TO BE A
TRUMP CRITIC, BUT APPARENTLY HE
IS DENOUNCING OR HAS DENOUNCED
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IN FAIRLY
HARSH TERMS THIS YEAR.
I'M TOLD BY SOURCES THAT HE HAS
EVEN GONE AS FAR AS TO SAY,
JOHN, THAT IF THE PRESIDENT WERE
TO -- THE FORMER PRESIDENT WERE
TO RUN AGAIN FOR THAT OFFICE,
THAT HE BELIEVES IT WOULD BE
DAMAGING, DAMAGING TO THE
COUNTRY.
NOW, THAT SAID, LACHLAN MURDOCH
IN PRIVATE ALSO STRESSED THAT
THE FOX NEWS AUDIENCE STILL
REMAINS LARGELY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
SO I THINK HE KNOWS THAT HE
MIGHT HAVE HIS OWN PERSONAL
FEELINGS REGARDING TRUMP, BUT
THE FOX AUDIENCE, IF THE CHANNEL
WERE TO OVERTLY BECOME CRITICAL
OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT, THEY
MIGHT DUMP THE CHANNEL AND FLEE
SOMEWHERE ELSE AND WE HAVE SEEN
THAT IN THE PAST.
AFTER THE 2020 ELECTION, SIZABLE
NUMBER OF VIEWERS LEFT FOX FOR
THOSE OTHER RIGHT WING CHANNELS,
AND EVEN MORE RECENTLY WHEN THE
CHANNEL CARRIES THE 1-6
HEARINGS, THE JANUARY 6th
HEARINGS, A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER
OF THE AUDIENCE TURNS OFF FOX
NEWS AND GOES SOMEWHERE ELSE OR
JUST STOPS WATCHING TELEVISION.
SO THERE ARE THOSE DATA POINTS
THAT WOULD INDICATE IF THE
CHANNEL DID CHANGE ITS TONE ON
TRUMP, IT WOULD BE A VERY BAD
BUSINESS DECISION, BUT LACHLAN
MURDOCH IN PRIVATE SEEMS TO BE
PRETTY CRITICAL OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> ANY SENSE HE WOULD GO PUBLIC
WITH HIS FIELDFEELINGS?
>> VERY UNLIKELY.
I DOUBT HE WOULD PREFER HIS
PRIVATE THOUGHTS TO BE DISCLOSED
PUBLICLY BECAUSE HE RUNS A
CHANNEL THAT IS SO PRO-TRUMP.
EVEN RECENTLY IN THE PAST WEEK
WE HAVE SEEN HOW FAR SOME
COMMENTATORS WILL GO TO SUPPORT
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WITH REGARD
TO THIS FBI SEARCH OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
SO, YOU ANY, I CAN'T IMAGINE A
WORLD IN WHICH HE WOULD WANT TO
BE PUBLICLY SEEN AS A TRUMP
CRITIC.
>> OLIVER DARCY, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US.
>> THANK YOU.
>>> TOP REPUBLICAN ALLIES OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE
REPORTEDLY URGING HIM TO SPEED
UP HIS TIMELINE FOR AN
ANNOUNCEMENT ON A 2024
PRESIDENTIAL BID WITH THE SEARCH
AT MAR-A-LAGO THE KEY FACTOR
CHANGING THEIR MINDS.
SEVERAL SOURCES TELL CNN THE
GROUP INCLUDES SOME REPUBLICANS
WHO PREVIOUSLY ADVISED TRUMP TO
WAIT UNTIL AFTER THE MIDTERMS.
JOINING US NOW IS CNN ANCHOR
CHRIS WALLACE, THE HOST OF
"WHO'S TALKING TO CHRIS
WALLACE."
CHRIS, SO GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE
AS ALWAYS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THIS,
THIS SPEEDING UP OF A TIMELINE
AND THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
REPUBLICANS NOW KIND OF MOVING
TO SUPPORT TRUMP, THAT MAYBE
WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN SO VOCIFEROUS
ABOUT IT BEFORE?
>> RIGHT NOW IT IS A RALLY
AROUND THE FLAG, IN THIS CASE
THE TRUMP FLAG.
HAVING SAID THAT, THERE ARE A AN
AWFUL LOT OF PEOPLE INSIDE THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY WHO HAVE ALWAYS
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A BAD IDEA
FOR TRUMP TO ANNOUNCE HE'S
RUNNING AGAIN BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS, AND INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH, ONE OF THE FEW PEOPLE
WHO YESTERDAY, EVEN AFTER THE
RAID, OR THE SEARCH, I SHOULD
SAY, SAID I THINK THAT WE
SHOULDN'T DO IT IS RONNA
McDANIEL, SHE SAID LET'S FOCUS
ON THE PLAYOFFS BEFORE WE WORRY
ABOUT THE SUPER BOWL.
AND I THINK THERE ARE REALLY TWO
REASONS, ONE, IF TRUMP WERE TO
ANNOUNCE TOMORROW THAT HE'S
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, A LOT OF
MONEY THAT MIGHT GO TO
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES FOR THE
MIDTERMS INSTEAD MIGHT GO TO THE
TRUMP 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
IN ADDITION TO WHICH HE
IMMEDIATELY SOAKS UP A LOT OF
THE OXYGEN AND INSTEAD OF THOSE
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES FOR THE
HOUSE, THE SENATE, GOVERNOR, ALL
THE WAY DOWN BEING ABLE TO FOCUS
ON JOE BIDEN AND INFLATION AND
CRIME AND ALL OF THOSE ISSUES,
THEY'RE ALL GOING TO BE ASKED
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THE RAID?
AND THE SMART REPUBLICANS I
TALKED TO THINK THAT ISN'T WHAT
THEY SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON, IN
THE LESS THAN 100 DAYS LEFT
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.